que je voudrais demander à madame quand
vous portez bonnes voiles seidman neutre
vous dites vous même c'est une
soumission à dieu
oui c'est un vrai symbole dont certains
disent c'est comme portable morceau de
tissu c'est pas la vérité vous êtes
d'accord donc c'est un symbole donc ça
veut dire quelque chose donc c'est un
message est ce que vous comprenez que
dans l'école le rôle justement de
l'école républicaine c'est de ne
soumettre nos enfants a aucun message
religieux a aucun message politique quel
qu'il soit c'est pas le voile en
particulier c'est tout ce qu'on peut
imaginer qu'ils puissent et influencés
dans leur épanouissement
la sortie scolaire ça fait partie du
temps scolaire c'est quelque chose qui
est obligatoire et c'est à visée
pédagogique donc la sortie scolaire
on doit protéger nos enfants de la même
façon votre voile c'est un message vous
avez le droit de passer ce message n'est
pas aux enfants qui sont à l'école de la
république et c'est pas vous offenser
imaginé pour mettre un tee shirt un
accompagnement scolaire met un t-shirt
non juifs non à ça ou voter un tel nom
mais la veille message beauté quelqu'un
quelques quelqu'un c'est pas un message
négatif la règle dans l'enceinte de
l'école c'est aucun message politique ni
religieux c'est la neutralité absolue
philosophiques religieuses et politiques
et la sortie scolaire doit suivre les
mêmes règles
c'est tout et si on accepter ça et qu'on
légiférer sur sa n'y aurait pas de
problème a déjà voilà la mort mais si je
peux me permettre
l'école en fait c'est l'éducation c'est
à dire qu'on apprend en fait au plus
petit âge aux enfants à respecter
l'autre si vous commencez à l'école à
dire que le voile est un problème le
voile ils vont rencontrer ils vont
rencontrer son bourg on est là de toute
façon dès que ce soit musulman pas
musulman les immigrés sont en france
alors qu'est ce que vous allez faire
vous n'allez pas faire quitter tous les
musulmans de france
donc les enfants qui vont grandir plus
tard vous rencontrer des personnes
voilées donc si vous mettez une sorte de
barrière des la base de l'éducation ça
va poser problème à déclaré madame parce
que je suis désolé moyenne il ya un
petit enfant qui m'a fait cette
réflexion en disant vous savez madame
vous avez pas le droit de porter le
foulard
je ne savais même pas trop quoi lui dire
donc déjà
la base vous êtes en train de ancrée
dans la tête des enfants que le foulard
porte un problème est alors ce foulard
bien parce qu'en fait c'est d'aider la
base donc ça la même chose rentrer dans
la retraite dès qu'ils vont voir
quelqu'un de voile et à celle entre une
société de tous les messages et de faire
une différence
malheureusement c'est il faut en fait
qui est des noirs déchaînée a dévoilé
des non voilée de ce sont en fait les
enfants apprennent à respecter tout le
monde
l'école c'est pas ça eric naulleau mais
moi je suis entre huy madame d'eric
naulleau
moi je suis pour une clarification que
les signes religieux
cela vous dit le voile non parle de tous
les signes religieux tousignant quand je
sais là maintenant aujourd'hui serait il
s'est basé sur le voile et simplement
mis sur laquelle je suis que wurz a que
des gens puissent montrer des signes
religieux s'ils sont dans des écoles
confessionnelles
les écoles confessionnelles sont faites
pour ça l'école laïque elle devrait être
aussi laïques pour les sorties dans
sorties scolaires il ya scolaire ce
serait beaucoup bien sûr mais ensuite il
ya beaucoup d'opinions qui sont exprimés
autour de cette table on peut pas dire
qui a tort qui a raison il ya une seule
instance qui a raison c'est la loi a
créé la loi-cadre ont pour l'instant la
loi vous autorise moi je souhaite que
cette loi change mais pour l'instant
vous avez droit à tout le respect voilà
d'accord moi c'est ma position
bonjour monsieur qu'est ce que vous
pensez de vous je suis en accord avec
eric naulleau sauf que la loi ne définit
pas une nation voyez la loi de 2004
allemand la loi de 2004 qui interdisait
les signes religieux à l'école et
notamment le voile à l'école
vous voyez bien on en attendait quand
même que les petites musulmane remise
leur voile dans les tiroirs et
s'intègrent et s'assimile au creuset
français
quinze ans après elles sont devenues
mamans et elles sont encore plus
nombreuses à être voilés donc voyez bien
que la loi la loi en elle-même ne crée
pas une identité nationale a pré palm
c'est ça c'est ça c'est la première
chose la deuxième chose c'est que
j'entends depuis tout à l'heure en
disant oui mais la kippa lacroix cetera
excusez moi aujourd'hui la menace qui
est enfant on va pas inventer des
menaces terroristes pouvaient pas on dit
non parce que j je dis simplement que il
y à une réalité on ne peut pas inventer
des réalités fantasme fantasmagorique
aujourd'hui il ya le communautarisme
islamistes qui est très puissant dans
certains territoires
il ya même un suprématisme musulmans qui
en fin de chaîne effectivement constitue
le terreau de gens qui paie qui pète un
câble a choisi air canada mais tu m'as
dit ça j'ai dit que c'est des degrés
genève il ya un terreau un terreau
communautarisme et une sur lequel
poussent et puis tout le monde et on
attendait peut pas nier terrorisme mais
si les terroristes existe alors je sais
bien que dans votre rue dans votre
logiciel ce sont tous des déséquilibrés
mais en l'occurrence ce sont des
terroristes simple au regard du ventre
il enfilé les terroristes viennent tous
les terroristes cause les ronces
terroriste pousse sur quel sur quel
terreau fertile sur mal à le terroriste
islamiste
je me sens en danger il me dit ma gynéco
et dans n'importe quel pays du monde
dans les pays du maghreb d une
communauté qui se mettent à s'habiller
en croisé raccourci qui ne saurait c'est
bon c'est vrai vous serez les premiers à
dire mais attendez il respecte pas loupé
alors qu'aucune loi locale l'interdît
voilà